here's five toxic chemicals in your food
right now
number one artificial food dyes found in
cakes and sports drinks and cheese and
candy and Froot Loops
if it's bright to the eye it's probably
dye artificial food dyes are linked to
hyperactivity and brain cancer but
conclusive research is elusive so
Billy's birthday cake is probably safe
for now
number two potassium bromate found in
rolls and wraps and breadcrumbs and
what-have-you it causes kidney damage
makes lab rats lumpy and will do the
same to you my friend
assuming you eat 33 pounds of raw bread
dough per day making the number-one
person at risk Kobayashi number 3 a's OD
carbon amide found in frozen dinners box
pasta and the like it's known to cause
asthma which makes it hard for Billy to
blow out his birthday candles but it
mostly causes asthma in its pure
chemical form and since your average TV
dinner has only 45 parts per million of
it you can enjoy your imitation
Salisbury steak guilt-free for the most
part number 4 arsenic bad news friend
farm-raised chicken contains arsenic and
scientists agree that you shouldn't eat
arsenic because arsenic is poison and
poison is bad for you but farm-raised
chicken has only 2.3 parts per billion
that's right billion of inorganic
arsenic in order for that to be toxic
you would have to eat all of the
chickens like every single one finally
number five olestra aka O lean olestra
is an alternative to cooking oil found
in fat-free potato chips side effects
include stomach cramps and leaky bowels
most scientists agree you should avoid
it probably because nobody likes leaky
bowels so in conclusion happy birthday
Billy chicken is not poisoned and only
eat fat-free chips if you want a dribbly
brownie
[Music]